Speaker 1: Normally, when we think about idealism, or
Speaker 1: what we could call utopian idealism, make
Speaker 1: it even more extreme.
Speaker 1: The idea of utopian idealism, or even the
Speaker 1: idea of utopia itself, is usually by very
Speaker 1: sophisticated, intelligent, philosophically
Speaker 1: oriented people, is often considered to be
Speaker 1: a non-rational, dangerous idea.
Speaker 1: So I'd like to speak about this
Speaker 1: non-rational, dangerous idea a little bit
Speaker 1: and let's see where we go with it.
Speaker 1: The interesting thing about enlightenment,
Speaker 1: the evolution of consciousness, the
Speaker 1: experience of higher states of
Speaker 1: consciousness that awakened us to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness, is that they reveal
Speaker 1: to us transrational truths about the nature
Speaker 1: of reality, that there are certain
Speaker 1: perspectives that we can glimpse in these
Speaker 1: higher states that we can directly
Speaker 1: experience that are definitely not rational
Speaker 1: at all.
Speaker 1: As a matter of fact, they can seem from a
Speaker 1: rational perspective as being very crazy.
Speaker 1: So I'd just like to start at the beginning
Speaker 1: and say that the higher truth, the higher
Speaker 1: truths that bestow upon us a glimpse of
Speaker 1: spiritual liberation and enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness, definitely transcend the
Speaker 1: category of anything we could call rational,
Speaker 1: and that's kind of the basis of what I want
Speaker 1: to speak about.
Speaker 1: I remember when I started on the path about
Speaker 1: 35 years ago, like many people, I was doing
Speaker 1: a lot of Buddhist meditation retreats,
Speaker 1: vipassana retreats, which many of us got
Speaker 1: trained in along the way, and I remember
Speaker 1: that my first spiritual teacher enlightened
Speaker 1: spiritual teachers, if they're
Speaker 1: authentically enlightened and authentically
Speaker 1: awake, have a capacity to convey a level of
Speaker 1: inspiration about our own potential.
Speaker 1: We're evolving at the level of
Speaker 1: consciousness and our own potential to
Speaker 1: glimpse enlightened states of awareness.
Speaker 1: If you see someone, spend time with someone,
Speaker 1: spend time in the presence of the company
Speaker 1: of someone who has access to these what I
Speaker 1: would call miraculous higher states of
Speaker 1: consciousness, those such individuals can
Speaker 1: convey to us and transmit to us what I
Speaker 1: would call miraculous higher states of
Speaker 1: consciousness.
Speaker 1: Those such individuals can convey to us and
Speaker 1: transmit to us or embody for us a higher
Speaker 1: potential for ourself.
Speaker 1: So I remember my first spiritual teacher
Speaker 1: was an Indian guru who died a long time ago.
Speaker 1: His name was Swami Hariharanandagiri and he
Speaker 1: was in the lineage of Kriya Yoga with
Speaker 1: Paramahansa, yogananda and his guru, sri
Speaker 1: Yukteswar, and I never met anybody like
Speaker 1: that before because he was always smiling
Speaker 1: and he wasn't a great speaker.
Speaker 1: He didn't give very good talks because his
Speaker 1: English and his rational faculty sometimes
Speaker 1: seemed a little incoherent, speaking of
Speaker 1: being rational.
Speaker 1: So his talks were.
Speaker 1: I found them quite incoherent and difficult
Speaker 1: to follow.
Speaker 1: But when he would laugh and he would giggle
Speaker 1: and he would smile.
Speaker 1: He would radiate the knowledge of a higher
Speaker 1: dimension of reality that I was desperate
Speaker 1: to gain access to, and he was very
Speaker 1: consistent in that.
Speaker 1: And he would do things like say he would
Speaker 1: say, my mango is very sweet.
Speaker 1: And he would often speak with unrestricted
Speaker 1: passion about his experience of higher
Speaker 1: states of consciousness and about how
Speaker 1: profound, how powerful, how extraordinary,
Speaker 1: how miraculous, how liberating they were
Speaker 1: and how this had changed his life and was
Speaker 1: continuing to change his life.
Speaker 1: And he spoke with such a sense of authority
Speaker 1: and honesty and integrity about these
Speaker 1: experiences that there was no doubt that he
Speaker 1: was speaking honestly about what was his
Speaker 1: own direct experience and honesty and
Speaker 1: integrity about these experiences that
Speaker 1: there was no doubt that he was speaking
Speaker 1: honestly about what was his own direct
Speaker 1: experience.
Speaker 1: And it was clear that his experience was
Speaker 1: very different than ours.
Speaker 1: He was living in a different plane of
Speaker 1: consciousness and his relationship to
Speaker 1: reality was very different because he had
Speaker 1: access to the entire states, and his access
Speaker 1: to those higher states made all the
Speaker 1: difference.
Speaker 1: So while I found in many ways his his, his
Speaker 1: I told you just to repeat when he gave
Speaker 1: talks, I found him quite incoherent when it
Speaker 1: came to being rational in terms of giving a
Speaker 1: talk.
Speaker 1: But beyond that, he conveyed the truth of
Speaker 1: the enlightenment that he was trying to
Speaker 1: share with us, trying to transmit to us and
Speaker 1: was so earnestly bearing witness to.
Speaker 1: So his example had a big effect on me.
Speaker 1: So, around the same time I met him, a
Speaker 1: friend of mine introduced me to Buddhism
Speaker 1: and to these long sitting retreats that one
Speaker 1: could go on for 10 days, 20 days, a few
Speaker 1: months at a time, and I remember I thought
Speaker 1: this was just fantastic.
Speaker 1: I said, wow, you can sit in this meditation
Speaker 1: hall for 16, 18, 20 hours a day if you want.
Speaker 1: And for me that was my idea of heaven at
Speaker 1: the time.
Speaker 1: But I remember this was a very different
Speaker 1: environment and all of the talks were very
Speaker 1: coherent, very rational, very consistent.
Speaker 1: They were philosophically consistent,
Speaker 1: metaphysically consistent and they created
Speaker 1: a metaphysical and philosophical framework
Speaker 1: that was very convincing and very intricate
Speaker 1: and ornate.
Speaker 1: But none of the teachers who were teaching
Speaker 1: us meditation, some of whom we've been at
Speaker 1: it for many, many, many years, conveyed
Speaker 1: anywhere near that sense of spontaneous joy
Speaker 1: and inner freedom that this Indian guru had.
Speaker 1: They knew all about enlightenment from a
Speaker 1: technical point of view, from a
Speaker 1: philosophical point of view and from a
Speaker 1: scriptural point of view, but none of them
Speaker 1: transmitted or conveyed it in the way he
Speaker 1: did so spontaneously, effortlessly and
Speaker 1: naturally.
Speaker 1: So I found this very confusing, because,
Speaker 1: whatever enlightenment is, he definitely
Speaker 1: found it and it had found him, whereas most
Speaker 1: of these other teachers seemed to me to be
Speaker 1: good teachers and good technicians and had
Speaker 1: a good grasp of the theory, but they didn't
Speaker 1: seem to be swimming in the altered state of
Speaker 1: consciousness that I was looking for.
Speaker 1: And then, finally, I met.
Speaker 1: Finally there was an English teacher who
Speaker 1: came to town, an English man who had been a
Speaker 1: monk for a long time, who was teaching the
Speaker 1: same practice, but he was different because
Speaker 1: he sometimes he would just start laughing
Speaker 1: spontaneously, he would hear that outburst
Speaker 1: of laughter and he would wink, and he
Speaker 1: seemed to know the secret.
Speaker 1: Whatever.
Speaker 1: Whatever the secret is, he was in on it.
Speaker 1: And he was the only teacher in that
Speaker 1: tradition that kind of inspired me to stick
Speaker 1: with it a little bit longer, because his
Speaker 1: laugh and his wink conveyed the fact that
Speaker 1: he, that he knew something mysterious that
Speaker 1: was the source of liberation, which is what
Speaker 1: we were trying to do.
Speaker 1: That's what the whole point of meditation
Speaker 1: is all about is to find liberation.
Speaker 1: And he wasn't just speaking about it, but
Speaker 1: he also was transmitting it in a way that
Speaker 1: was compelling.
Speaker 1: And what people who awaken to enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness convey is transrational knowledge,
Speaker 1: transrational knowing, transrational gnosis,
Speaker 1: and it's important to understand this.
Speaker 1: I'm not advocating excuse me that the mind
Speaker 1: is not a very important friend, very
Speaker 1: important friend, and I've always been a
Speaker 1: great believer in a fiercely rational
Speaker 1: spirituality and I think I've been a fairly
Speaker 1: consistent proponent and exemplar of a
Speaker 1: rational approach to enlightenment.
Speaker 1: So I am very much, I try to be a rational
Speaker 1: guy as much as I can, but I get the sense
Speaker 1: these days in some very sophisticated
Speaker 1: circles when it comes to higher states of
Speaker 1: consciousness and the possibility of
Speaker 1: awakening to enlightened awareness.
Speaker 1: I think too many people are losing the plot
Speaker 1: aligned awareness.
Speaker 1: I think it's too many people losing the
Speaker 1: plot Because without getting to that point
Speaker 1: when we actually transcend our rational
Speaker 1: faculties in a way that is radical and
Speaker 1: quite extreme, we're never going to take
Speaker 1: the leap beyond the mind.
Speaker 1: It's all about taking that leap beyond the
Speaker 1: mind.
Speaker 1: So unless we're willing to dispense with
Speaker 1: our rational faculties for a period of time,
Speaker 1: we'll never be able to glimpse what lays
Speaker 1: beyond the mind, and that's where the
Speaker 1: secret is, that's where the mystery abides.
Speaker 1: And when I finally met my guru, the great
Speaker 1: HWL Punjo, the disciple of Ramana Maharshi,
Speaker 1: in 1986.
Speaker 1: His calm, abiding in an altered state of
Speaker 1: consciousness beyond the mind, was
Speaker 1: absolutely amazing.
Speaker 1: And he spoke about enlightenment, or
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness, with a sense of
Speaker 1: immediacy that I found quite shocking.
Speaker 1: When I met him, he started taking my own
Speaker 1: potential for enlightenment more seriously
Speaker 1: than I was and I was a pretty serious guy,
Speaker 1: still am.
Speaker 1: But I never met somebody who seemed to be
Speaker 1: so acquainted with enlightenment from
Speaker 1: direct experience and he spoke about it so,
Speaker 1: like my first group, he spoke about it so
Speaker 1: passionately and so directly from what
Speaker 1: seemed to be the immediacy of his own
Speaker 1: experience.
Speaker 1: Enlightenment for him was not far away, it
Speaker 1: was here and now and he was transmitting it,
Speaker 1: he was radiating it and the strangest
Speaker 1: things would happen around him.
Speaker 1: One day I was sitting with him in his
Speaker 1: living room and a rather ordinary older
Speaker 1: Indian woman came in.
Speaker 1: She didn't look remarkable in any way and
Speaker 1: he said ask her about her experience, she's
Speaker 1: enlightened.
Speaker 1: And I said, and I thought he must be crazy.
Speaker 1: I didn't know where.
Speaker 1: I thought she said she sounded absurd and
Speaker 1: ridiculous.
Speaker 1: He said no, no, andrew, go and speak to her,
Speaker 1: ask her about her experience.
Speaker 1: So I can't remember the question I asked
Speaker 1: her, but I asked her some questions about
Speaker 1: meditation and, without missing a beat,
Speaker 1: without hesitating, he said oh, that's good
Speaker 1: for beginners.
Speaker 1: And she said it with a totally straight
Speaker 1: face and she responded quicker, quicker,
Speaker 1: the faster than thought.
Speaker 1: She said oh, that's good for beginners.
Speaker 1: So her spiritual self-confidence, in terms
Speaker 1: of awakening to enlightened awareness was
Speaker 1: unparalleled and something I'd never seen.
Speaker 1: I'd never seen this before.
Speaker 1: I'd never met people who had this kind of,
Speaker 1: I'd never met so many people, in such a
Speaker 1: short period of time, who seemed to have
Speaker 1: access to enlightened awareness.
Speaker 1: This made a very powerful impression on me.
Speaker 1: So so If the goal is to gain spiritual
Speaker 1: self-confidence, if the goal is to awaken
Speaker 1: to enlightened awareness, then we've got to
Speaker 1: do whatever we need to do to gain access,
Speaker 1: to succeed in our endeavor to awaken, to
Speaker 1: gain access, to succeed in our endeavor to
Speaker 1: awaken.
Speaker 1: I personally feel very passionately that if
Speaker 1: enlightenment is what we're compelled by
Speaker 1: the promise of enlightenment, the potential
Speaker 1: for enlightenment, then we've got to give
Speaker 1: it everything we've got.
Speaker 1: We've got to do anything and everything we
Speaker 1: can to have these experiences of higher
Speaker 1: states of consciousness that blow our mind
Speaker 1: and blow our heart wide open, and I think
Speaker 1: we need to stop pretending that that is not
Speaker 1: the most important thing, because it is
Speaker 1: being utterly knocked over and overwhelmed
Speaker 1: by the potential of consciousness.
Speaker 1: To reveal the ultimate truth about the
Speaker 1: nature of reality is what this is all about
Speaker 1: and what it's always been about and what
Speaker 1: it's always going to be about.
Speaker 1: Psychotherapy can help us to clean up our
Speaker 1: act, but it won't help to liberate us, not
Speaker 1: in the end.
Speaker 1: And the thing about higher states is
Speaker 1: they're very elusive, they're very
Speaker 1: mysterious.
Speaker 1: They can be here one day and gone tomorrow.
Speaker 1: And one of the most mysterious things about
Speaker 1: higher states of consciousness I've come to
Speaker 1: find from the perspective of teaching is
Speaker 1: that I've seen over the years, countless
Speaker 1: people wake up to these higher states and,
Speaker 1: when they're in these higher states,
Speaker 1: glimpse the ultimate or absolute nature of
Speaker 1: reality and, as a result, become absolutely
Speaker 1: illuminated or lit up by the fire of
Speaker 1: consciousness and the knowing of
Speaker 1: consciousness, the knowing of non-duality
Speaker 1: from their own inner experience, from their
Speaker 1: own direct experience, and that, as we know,
Speaker 1: at least temporarily, changes everything.
Speaker 1: When you directly experience the non-dual
Speaker 1: or absolute nature of reality.
Speaker 1: Your mind is thrown out the window and you
Speaker 1: begin to see reality through a different
Speaker 1: lens.
Speaker 1: And that different lens changes everything
Speaker 1: because there is inherent in the vision of
Speaker 1: non-duality and the direct experience of
Speaker 1: non-duality.
Speaker 1: Non-duality is not just the conscious
Speaker 1: perception or conscious cognition of a
Speaker 1: great singularity of all is one and one is
Speaker 1: all, as you all have heard about.
Speaker 1: That's part of it.
Speaker 1: Experiencing the inherent non-dual
Speaker 1: singularity that is all of reality is a
Speaker 1: part of it.
Speaker 1: It's an important part of it.
Speaker 1: But I think what's more important is that
Speaker 1: in the radiance of the non-dual vision, in
Speaker 1: the radiance of the non-dual experience, in
Speaker 1: the radiance of the non-dual knowing, there
Speaker 1: is a direct gnosis of a indescribable and
Speaker 1: overwhelming pure positivity.
Speaker 1: But it's a pure positivity that is
Speaker 1: transrational and non-relative.
Speaker 1: Non-relative means the totality of reality
Speaker 1: falls into two categories.
Speaker 1: According to Mahayana Buddhism, there's a
Speaker 1: distinction between what's called relative
Speaker 1: reality and absolute reality.
Speaker 1: Relative reality and absolute reality are
Speaker 1: two different dimensions of cognition, of
Speaker 1: perception and of existence and
Speaker 1: manifestation, of perception and of
Speaker 1: existence and manifestation.
Speaker 1: So relative reality is the place where the
Speaker 1: unenlightened mind and unenlightened
Speaker 1: consciousness and cognition predominate.
Speaker 1: Manifest reality, manifest reality,
Speaker 1: so-called normal state of consciousness.
Speaker 1: But when we awaken to absolute reality,
Speaker 1: this non-relative dimension of
Speaker 1: consciousness.
Speaker 1: It's a flip from one dimension to another.
Speaker 1: And in this definitely higher dimension
Speaker 1: there is the unequivocal, undoubted
Speaker 1: recognition in this higher state, that what
Speaker 1: one is experiencing, or the way one is
Speaker 1: seeing and feeling and knowing reality in
Speaker 1: that higher state that is non-relative, is
Speaker 1: that this non-relative perception is
Speaker 1: inherently more real.
Speaker 1: And everybody who makes this slip says oh
Speaker 1: my goodness, in this state of consciousness
Speaker 1: I'm experiencing reality with much more
Speaker 1: depth and authenticity.
Speaker 1: This is real.
Speaker 1: In comparison to this state of
Speaker 1: consciousness, relative reality is seen to
Speaker 1: be unreal.
Speaker 1: But in this higher state of non-relative
Speaker 1: perception, consciousness and cognition,
Speaker 1: I'm experiencing reality as being
Speaker 1: infinitely more real.
Speaker 1: This is real.
Speaker 1: And in comparison to this absolute
Speaker 1: perception of greater reality, relative
Speaker 1: reality is seen and felt as being unreal.
Speaker 1: And this is a very important distinction,
Speaker 1: because if it's true and it is true, but
Speaker 1: you have to have the experience to know
Speaker 1: that it's true would you want to live in a
Speaker 1: relationship to reality that's
Speaker 1: fundamentally recognized to be unreal and
Speaker 1: false and partial, or would you want to
Speaker 1: have a relationship to reality that is real
Speaker 1: and absolute and intoxicating?
Speaker 1: So the point I wanted to make was that
Speaker 1: inherent in the non-dual vision is the
Speaker 1: direct perception, the direct gnosis or
Speaker 1: cognition of pure positivity.
Speaker 1: That inherent in this ultimate or absolute
Speaker 1: perspective is a knowledge or a knowing of
Speaker 1: reality itself in its essence that is
Speaker 1: indescribably positive, overwhelmingly
Speaker 1: positive and conceivably positive.
Speaker 1: It's a recognition that the very essence of
Speaker 1: reality, which is not a thing, the very
Speaker 1: essence of the very heart of reality itself,
Speaker 1: in the very essence or in the very heart of
Speaker 1: reality itself, is a pure positivity.
Speaker 1: It's absolutely undefiled by anything that
Speaker 1: the mind can come up with.
Speaker 1: It's what happens when you see the face of
Speaker 1: God.
Speaker 1: You recognize a purity and a perfection
Speaker 1: that is mind-boggling, awe-inspiring.
Speaker 1: That's what brings us to our knees.
Speaker 1: It's the direct cognition of this pure
Speaker 1: positivity that's so life-transforming.
Speaker 1: And we know this is very important because
Speaker 1: smart, sensitive, thoughtful people want to
Speaker 1: know is existence a good thing?
Speaker 1: When something came from nothing, was it a
Speaker 1: big yes, was it a from nothing?
Speaker 1: Was it a big yes, was it a big no?
Speaker 1: Was it a big neutral?
Speaker 1: Is life inherently good or is life
Speaker 1: inherently a bad trip, as most people seem
Speaker 1: to feel that it is?
Speaker 1: And we have to take this seriously because
Speaker 1: a lot of the smartest, most sensitive,
Speaker 1: thoughtful people haven't had the kind of
Speaker 1: awakening I'm describing to you and are
Speaker 1: therefore not so sure that life is
Speaker 1: inherently a good thing, because there's so
Speaker 1: much suffering, so much confusion, so much
Speaker 1: fear, so much doubt, so much depression,
Speaker 1: anxiety, self-concern, terror.
Speaker 1: So when we make this leap from relative
Speaker 1: reality to absolute reality, and in this
Speaker 1: leap from absolute reality we glimpse, we
Speaker 1: have a direct cognosis or cognition of the
Speaker 1: fact that inherent in the ultimate nature
Speaker 1: of reality is a pure positivity.
Speaker 1: Inherent in the ultimate nature of reality
Speaker 1: is a pure positivity, a pure positivity,
Speaker 1: that is its nature, is purely positive, the
Speaker 1: essence of reality itself.
Speaker 1: Don't take my word for it.
Speaker 1: I'm just saying, if you have the experience,
Speaker 1: you'll see that it's true.
Speaker 1: That's why people who are truly enlightened
Speaker 1: which means they have access to these
Speaker 1: higher states on a regular basis when you
Speaker 1: go deep enough into these experiences of
Speaker 1: higher states, it changes you.
Speaker 1: It changes you at a level of the soul,
Speaker 1: because you know this absolute truth beyond
Speaker 1: the mind, by the way, beyond the rational
Speaker 1: mind.
Speaker 1: And you know that it's true.
Speaker 1: Even if the whole world is going to hell,
Speaker 1: with everyone in it, it doesn't change the
Speaker 1: absolute truth.
Speaker 1: And if you know that, it gives you
Speaker 1: spiritual self-confidenceconfidence, even
Speaker 1: if you're on the titanic, it's not that you
Speaker 1: don't care.
Speaker 1: You do care, but you know that whatever is
Speaker 1: going to happen on that ship won't
Speaker 1: ultimately change the highest and deepest
Speaker 1: truth about the ultimate nature of reality,
Speaker 1: which is that inherent in this mysterious
Speaker 1: process called existence, inherent at the
Speaker 1: very core level of existence, is a pure
Speaker 1: positivity that's indescribable and,
Speaker 1: ultimately, completely overwhelming.
Speaker 1: So so there's this distinction between
Speaker 1: relative reality and absolute reality, and
Speaker 1: we get these glimpses of this pure
Speaker 1: positivity indescribable pure positivity
Speaker 1: when we awaken to the non-relative,
Speaker 1: absolute dimension of reality, and you know,
Speaker 1: as a higher, as an experience of a higher
Speaker 1: state of consciousness.
Speaker 1: Now, what we'll notice is that most of the
Speaker 1: great realizers not only had a profound
Speaker 1: awakening to non-relative absolute reality,
Speaker 1: but their awakening was usually so deep, so
Speaker 1: profound, so life-transforming, so
Speaker 1: mesmerizing, that they came back from these
Speaker 1: higher states with a great vision, a vision
Speaker 1: of the possible, a vision of heaven on
Speaker 1: earth, a vision of utopia.
Speaker 1: The experience of these higher states of
Speaker 1: consciousness inspire most realizers to try
Speaker 1: to bring this vision of perfection, this
Speaker 1: experience of perfection, to try to bring
Speaker 1: it into manifest relative reality.
Speaker 1: This is when things get tricky and you just
Speaker 1: go wrong.
Speaker 1: Go wrong, but before we get there, I just
Speaker 1: want to make this point that the deepest
Speaker 1: and most profoundly life-changing
Speaker 1: experiences of higher states of
Speaker 1: consciousness almost always not in every
Speaker 1: case, but almost always inspire the
Speaker 1: realizer to want to transform relative
Speaker 1: reality, the world of time and space, self
Speaker 1: and other world and culture, to want to
Speaker 1: transcend the relative world, relative
Speaker 1: reality, into a vision of absolute reality.
Speaker 1: Which means I've been to heaven, I've seen
Speaker 1: heaven, heaven is real, heaven exists.
Speaker 1: And now I want to try and create heaven on
Speaker 1: earth.
Speaker 1: It's called the utopian vision.
Speaker 1: In Mahayana Buddhism they call it the land
Speaker 1: of Shambhala.
Speaker 1: So it seems that in most cases that
Speaker 1: inherent in the profound spiritual
Speaker 1: realization is the inspired compulsion to
Speaker 1: try and create this heavenly realm, to turn
Speaker 1: this heavenly realm that we experience as a
Speaker 1: spiritual state or as a vision.
Speaker 1: We want to try and transform the relative
Speaker 1: world into that vision, to make that vision
Speaker 1: come alive and manifest reality.
Speaker 1: And that's what all spiritual groups and
Speaker 1: spiritual cults throughout history have
Speaker 1: tried to do.
Speaker 1: They wanted to come together, awaken to
Speaker 1: these higher states of consciousness, have
Speaker 1: the spiritual vision and try to actualize
Speaker 1: it in this world, more often than not
Speaker 1: failing miserably.
Speaker 1: But I want you just to get an idea of how
Speaker 1: this works.
Speaker 1: this works, because these vision of
Speaker 1: perfection that we experience becomes clear
Speaker 1: to us when we wake into enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness.
Speaker 1: It's not just the experience of inherent
Speaker 1: perfection at the very core of reality, but
Speaker 1: it's also we see what's possible beyond the
Speaker 1: mind, beyond fear, beyond doubt, beyond
Speaker 1: duality, beyond division, beyond ego
Speaker 1: individual ego, cultural ego, tribal ego,
Speaker 1: male ego, female ego, beyond all
Speaker 1: differences of self and other, world and
Speaker 1: cosmos, beyond all differences, there's a
Speaker 1: vision of what's possible.
Speaker 1: When you experience these higher states of
Speaker 1: consciousness, you see, this is the truth.
Speaker 1: This is the truth, this is the truth.
Speaker 1: And if you really have a very strong
Speaker 1: experience, you want, you feel yourself
Speaker 1: hopelessly compelled to try to mold the
Speaker 1: relative world, relative real, in that
Speaker 1: image.
Speaker 1: Good luck, but that's how it works, that's
Speaker 1: how it always works.
Speaker 1: So I want everybody to understand this
Speaker 1: utopian idealism as a product of the
Speaker 1: experience of higher states of
Speaker 1: consciousness, when they're very deep.
Speaker 1: Because when you've seen this perfection
Speaker 1: and this inconceivable goodness, when it's
Speaker 1: touched your heart so deeply, you want to
Speaker 1: share it, it wants to be known and you feel
Speaker 1: that it wants to be known through you.
Speaker 1: And so there comes upon you an
Speaker 1: indescribable compulsion to bear witness to
Speaker 1: the possible.
Speaker 1: I've seen what's possible.
Speaker 1: I've experienced what's possible.
Speaker 1: I know what's possible.
Speaker 1: Now I want to try and make it happen.
Speaker 1: Does anybody have anything better to do?
Speaker 1: Self-compromise maybe.
Speaker 1: When you've seen what's possible and
Speaker 1: experienced what's possible in such a way
Speaker 1: that it's so utterly, utterly radical and
Speaker 1: utterly uncompromised, a truly inspired
Speaker 1: person feels there's nothing left for me to
Speaker 1: do, but then to do whatever I can do to
Speaker 1: actualize this extraordinary truth, this
Speaker 1: vision, in relative reality.
Speaker 1: That's the transformation of the interior
Speaker 1: of the cosmos.
Speaker 1: I want to transform the interior of the
Speaker 1: cosmos from this bleak dimension of fear
Speaker 1: and insecurity to one of love and joy and
Speaker 1: celebration.
Speaker 1: This is what spiritually inspired people
Speaker 1: feel like, even if they're crazy, so so.
Speaker 1: So, in this vision of absolute reality, we
Speaker 1: glimpse perfection, and I want to make it
Speaker 1: very clear, as I often do on this point,
Speaker 1: that we can glimpse perfection in a higher
Speaker 1: state of consciousness.
Speaker 1: We can glimpse perfection, we can see it,
Speaker 1: we can feel it, we can know that which is
Speaker 1: perfect, absolutely perfect, indescribably
Speaker 1: perfect, unimaginably perfect.
Speaker 1: But relative reality is part of a process,
Speaker 1: part of an evolutionary and creative
Speaker 1: process that's in a process of constant
Speaker 1: change and development.
Speaker 1: Relative reality is not static.
Speaker 1: Relative reality is, as the Buddha himself
Speaker 1: stated, in a state of constant change,
Speaker 1: development, rising and falling, moving and
Speaker 1: changing.
Speaker 1: So we can never reach perfection in
Speaker 1: relative reality.
Speaker 1: Perfection cannot be attained in relative
Speaker 1: reality.
Speaker 1: We can see perfection, experience
Speaker 1: perfection and know perfection in a vision
Speaker 1: of absolute reality.
Speaker 1: We can know perfection, undoubtedly, in a
Speaker 1: vision of absolute reality, in the
Speaker 1: experience of absolute reality, in the
Speaker 1: awakening to absolute reality, but we can't
Speaker 1: attain perfection in relative reality.
Speaker 1: It's unattainable because we're in a
Speaker 1: developmental process where the the
Speaker 1: unattainable because we're in a
Speaker 1: developmental process where the, where the
Speaker 1: we're always reaching for something that's
Speaker 1: possible but never ultimately reached or
Speaker 1: attained.
Speaker 1: So, in absolute reality, we can glimpse
Speaker 1: perfection.
Speaker 1: Relative reality, we can't attain
Speaker 1: We can, but we can reach for it.
Speaker 1: And this is the kicker.
Speaker 1: If you reach for perfection in relative
Speaker 1: reality, whether you're a tennis player or
Speaker 1: a photographer or a musician or a
Speaker 1: philosopher, if you reach with all of your
Speaker 1: heart and all of your might and all of your
Speaker 1: soul, if you reach for relative, if you
Speaker 1: reach for perfection, you're gonna get a
Speaker 1: lot closer to reaching it than if you don't
Speaker 1: even try.
Speaker 1: So, once again, we can glimpse perfection
Speaker 1: in absolute reality, but we can't attain
Speaker 1: perfection in relative reality, but don't
Speaker 1: give up.
Speaker 1: A lot of people realize this and then they
Speaker 1: say, well, there's no point in even trying
Speaker 1: that I might as well just accept things as
Speaker 1: they are, which is a very popular spiritual
Speaker 1: technique Be with what is and accept things
Speaker 1: as they are.
Speaker 1: Why Things can be so much better than they
Speaker 1: are, so much more extraordinary, profound,
Speaker 1: miraculous, amazing.
Speaker 1: They really can.
Speaker 1: But you've got to believe it and don't take
Speaker 1: my word for it, the only way you're going
Speaker 1: to believe it.
Speaker 1: If you have these experiences that
Speaker 1: demonstrate it to you in your own soul,
Speaker 1: then you're going to know oh, things could
Speaker 1: be so much better.
Speaker 1: I've experienced so much joy, peace and
Speaker 1: happiness, exhilaration, love, ecstasy and
Speaker 1: so much pure potential.
Speaker 1: That kind of experience inspires us to want
Speaker 1: to reach higher and to reach higher and to
Speaker 1: reach higher.
Speaker 1: So, once again, how I see this making sense
Speaker 1: and it's working is that if we glimpse
Speaker 1: these higher states which show us the
Speaker 1: ultimate nature of reality as it is, those
Speaker 1: higher state experiences can inspire us to
Speaker 1: reach higher and farther.
Speaker 1: Within the context of relative reality, in
Speaker 1: the context of this human experience of
Speaker 1: being human, the higher we reach, the more
Speaker 1: extraordinary the potentials are going to
Speaker 1: be that emerge through us.
Speaker 1: So, how high are we reaching?
Speaker 1: How far are we actually trying to go?
Speaker 1: Are we reaching for the stars?
Speaker 1: Because, for those people who reach for the
Speaker 1: stars, see things, know things, understand
Speaker 1: things in a way that people who don't reach
Speaker 1: for the stars are never going to know.
Speaker 1: So the way I see it is that the experience
Speaker 1: of higher states of consciousness can be
Speaker 1: sources of non-relative or absolute
Speaker 1: inspiration.
Speaker 1: Inspiration to reach higher, to try harder,
Speaker 1: to have even more faith, to have even more
Speaker 1: faith, to have even more faith oh, my
Speaker 1: goodness, really, yes, to have even more
Speaker 1: faith and to be willing to make more effort
Speaker 1: and not to settle for less than everything.
Speaker 1: And if I'm not willing to settle for less
Speaker 1: than everything and you're not willing to
Speaker 1: settle for less than everything, then
Speaker 1: together, as we engage with each other in
Speaker 1: this human drama, our mutual yearning and
Speaker 1: reaching will catalyze higher possibilities
Speaker 1: and higher potentials to emerge between us.
Speaker 1: So, but what's very important?
Speaker 1: It's very important to know that that
Speaker 1: perfection can be seen, but it can't be
Speaker 1: actualized.
Speaker 1: You can see that which is perfect and you
Speaker 1: can experience that which is perfect, but
Speaker 1: you can never reach it, you can never
Speaker 1: actualize it, you can never manifest
Speaker 1: perfection, you can never actualize it, you
Speaker 1: can never manifest perfection.
Speaker 1: No human being can manifest perfection.
Speaker 1: But we can all experience perfection.
Speaker 1: And the more we experience perfection, the
Speaker 1: more we're going to want to try to
Speaker 1: actualize it and manifest it, the more
Speaker 1: we're going to be inspired to do everything
Speaker 1: we can to actualize it and manifest it.
Speaker 1: And that gives rise to what I call creative
Speaker 1: evolutionary tension.
Speaker 1: And if we're spiritually inspired, we want
Speaker 1: to kind of actualize this evolutionary
Speaker 1: tension.
Speaker 1: And what will inspire us to actualize that
Speaker 1: evolutionary tension in the context of the
Speaker 1: relative reality of our relative lives is
Speaker 1: the vision and direct gnosis and cognition
Speaker 1: of absolute non-duality, directly
Speaker 1: experiencing the inherent perfection that
Speaker 1: lies at the very center of everything.
Speaker 1: That is so why do I chose the title
Speaker 1: Rational Idealism?
Speaker 1: Rational Idealism is that we want to have
Speaker 1: the audacious courage to embrace utopian
Speaker 1: idealism in all its promise, while having a
Speaker 1: fiercely rational understanding of the way
Speaker 1: reality actually works, knowing that we're
Speaker 1: never going to actually be able to
Speaker 1: actualize it.
Speaker 1: We want to hold that paradox very much
Speaker 1: alive in our hands and heart.
Speaker 1: I see utopia as an experience, as a higher
Speaker 1: state of consciousness, and I want the
Speaker 1: world that I'm living in and I'm
Speaker 1: co-creating with everyone else to become an
Speaker 1: expression of that utopian vision, while
Speaker 1: fully knowing that we're never going to get
Speaker 1: there.
Speaker 1: And even though I know we're never going to
Speaker 1: get there, and even though I know we're
Speaker 1: never going to get there, we're going to
Speaker 1: try.
Speaker 1: We're being mediated and moderated by
Speaker 1: rational discrimination, which should keep
Speaker 1: us sane, because if we're not careful, if
Speaker 1: we try to actualize perfection in a context
Speaker 1: in which it can never be actualized, we're
Speaker 1: going to make a mess.
Speaker 1: This is why so many utopian experiments
Speaker 1: have failed so miserably because this
Speaker 1: distinction between absolute truth and
Speaker 1: relative truth was not understood.
Speaker 1: Relative reality is relative reality.
Speaker 1: Because this distinction between absolute
Speaker 1: truth and relative truth was not understood,
Speaker 1: relative reality is relative reality and it
Speaker 1: can only always go so far.
Speaker 1: But if we are trying to revolutionize
Speaker 1: relative reality inspired by a vision of
Speaker 1: absolute reality, the world that we're
Speaker 1: living in, we're co-creating together, can
Speaker 1: become such an extraordinarily profoundly
Speaker 1: positive, co-creative reflection of the
Speaker 1: possible.
Speaker 1: But what a delicate paradox.
Speaker 1: We all have to learn how to hold.
Speaker 1: To repeat we can all know that which is
Speaker 1: perfect, but we can never know that which
Speaker 1: is perfect, but we can never be that which
Speaker 1: is perfect.
Speaker 1: We can know that which is perfect, but we
Speaker 1: can never be that which is perfect.
Speaker 1: It doesn't intimidate me if we have fragile,
Speaker 1: if we have fragile egos, oh, I can't be
Speaker 1: perfect.
Speaker 1: Will I give up?
Speaker 1: No, we got to grow up and be stronger than
Speaker 1: that.
Speaker 1: No, we can't be perfect, we're never going
Speaker 1: to reach perfection.
Speaker 1: But but we want to try and reach it.
Speaker 1: We want to try and reach the perfection
Speaker 1: anyway, fully knowing beforehand that we're
Speaker 1: never going to get there.
Speaker 1: And that's where the action is, that's
Speaker 1: where the that's where evolutionary
Speaker 1: emergence comes from.
Speaker 1: Holding that tension, tension, that paradox,
Speaker 1: it requires a bit of spiritual heroism and
Speaker 1: metaphysical exuberance and audacity, and
Speaker 1: learning how to hold these two truths is a
Speaker 1: big part of what it means to be a mature
Speaker 1: realizer Holding the paradox, embracing the
Speaker 1: paradox and living the paradox earnestly.
Speaker 1: So, for example, if we're truly audacious,
Speaker 1: we want to have the courage to bear witness
Speaker 1: to that perfection in a cynical world
Speaker 1: that's so full of doubt and arrogance and
Speaker 1: nihilism.
Speaker 1: That takes courage To bear witness, to
Speaker 1: choose to bear witness, as yourself, to
Speaker 1: that perfection in such a cynical,
Speaker 1: nihilistic, doubtful, fearful, angry world
Speaker 1: space.
Speaker 1: That takes courage.
Speaker 1: As I always like to say, consciousness
Speaker 1: delights in its own self-recognition.
Speaker 1: So, if I can share my awakened inspiration
Speaker 1: with you, it can awaken that same
Speaker 1: inspiration in you.
Speaker 1: And if you catch fire, you can awaken that
Speaker 1: same inspiration in you.
Speaker 1: same inspiration in others.
Speaker 1: So, while I feel that our metaphysical
Speaker 1: aspirations need to be mediated and
Speaker 1: moderated by a ferocious, rational,
Speaker 1: contemplative, observing vision, we don't
Speaker 1: want, we don't want the the unbelievable
Speaker 1: potential that exists to be suffocated by
Speaker 1: being too rational about all this.
Speaker 1: We want to use our rational faculties too
Speaker 1: rational about all this.
Speaker 1: We wanna use our rational faculties to help
Speaker 1: us stay on the right track, but we don't
Speaker 1: want them to suffocate and snuff out the
Speaker 1: fire of unconditional liberation, as it can
Speaker 1: and as it does and as it will.
Speaker 1: If we're not careful, if we get too smart
Speaker 1: about all this, we can kill God without
Speaker 1: even knowing we're doing it because we're
Speaker 1: just too smart for our own good.
Speaker 1: As long as we privilege the mind, in the
Speaker 1: end God's going to disappear.
Speaker 1: So we want to learn how to be very
Speaker 1: sophisticated thinkers while simultaneously
Speaker 1: being experts and transcending the mind and
Speaker 1: throwing it into the garbage can when
Speaker 1: necessary, which is probably every day a
Speaker 1: few times.
Speaker 1: So this is why I use the title rational
Speaker 1: idealism.
Speaker 1: Now you can understand why I think we need
Speaker 1: to have the courage to be idealistic.
Speaker 1: It takes guts.
Speaker 1: It's not cool to be too idealistic, people
Speaker 1: think.
Speaker 1: If you get too idealistic, too inspired by
Speaker 1: this pure positivity, people think you're
Speaker 1: naive, foolish, dangerous and so probably.
Speaker 1: But deep and profound realizers are wild
Speaker 1: characters who've shunned convention.
Speaker 1: They're not afraid of the audacious nature
Speaker 1: of this pure positivity.
Speaker 1: They're not afraid to be exemplars of it in
Speaker 1: the face of this believing world.
Speaker 1: And that's a challenge for all of us.
Speaker 1: If we're sincere, I believe Just to repeat,
Speaker 1: we can experience perfection, but we can't
Speaker 1: be perfection.
Speaker 1: It doesn't mean we shouldn't always try to
Speaker 1: be better, try to be more perfect, and we
Speaker 1: want to try and embrace the tension between,
Speaker 1: the tension inherent in reaching for
Speaker 1: perfection that can't be reached.
Speaker 1: We want to try to give this higher
Speaker 1: consciousness no excuse not to work through
Speaker 1: us.
Speaker 1: If we leave too much room for self-doubt
Speaker 1: and self-hatred and self-loathing, fear,
Speaker 1: depression, nihilism and arrogance, the
Speaker 1: consciousness won't show its face.
Speaker 1: We need to be worthy vehicles of this
Speaker 1: vision of perfection, which means you've
Speaker 1: got to believe in it, you've got to trust
Speaker 1: in it and have great, so much faith, and
Speaker 1: this consciousness will know if that's your
Speaker 1: position.
Speaker 1: If you have that much faith and have that
Speaker 1: much conviction, that consciousness will
Speaker 1: reveal itself to you, within you most part,
Speaker 1: to speak through you.
Speaker 1: So while we need the mind, we need to be
Speaker 1: good thinkers, to be smart people, to help
Speaker 1: us make the right choices.
Speaker 1: We don't want to be a slave to rational
Speaker 1: thinking.
Speaker 1: We don't want the rational mind to be our
Speaker 1: God, our servant.
Speaker 1: Enlightened awareness is not reasonable,
Speaker 1: it's not rational, it's unreasonable and
Speaker 1: transrational.
Speaker 1: It doesn't fit in to anything.
Speaker 1: It uploads everything out of the water.
Speaker 1: So we want to try and have liberated and
Speaker 1: unconditioned awareness.
Speaker 1: Liberated, unconditioned, enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness and rational thinking, but not
Speaker 1: rational thinking, and then a little bit of
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness.
Speaker 1: You let go of the mind.
Speaker 1: You have to let go of your ego too, because
Speaker 1: the two work together.
Speaker 1: A lot of people want to let go of their
Speaker 1: mind, but their mind doesn't seem to want
Speaker 1: to go.
Speaker 1: They don't realize that it's because their
Speaker 1: ego is trying to let go, trying to do the
Speaker 1: letting go.
Speaker 1: It doesn't work that way.
Speaker 1: Your ego will never let go of your mind.
Speaker 1: It'll never let go of the mind.
Speaker 1: So if your ego, as you, usurped your
Speaker 1: spiritual impulse, if your ego is trying to
Speaker 1: get enlightened, it ain't never going to
Speaker 1: work, of course.
Speaker 1: So the difficult part in all this and it
Speaker 1: sounds very mundane or trite even, but it's
Speaker 1: true, and if you want to awaken to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness, to transrational
Speaker 1: gnosis, consciousness and cognition, the
Speaker 1: ego's got to take a hike, it has to go away,
Speaker 1: it has to be transcended, fiercely,
Speaker 1: ferociously, absolutely and completely.
Speaker 1: At least for a few moments, you have to be
Speaker 1: able to stand free from your ego.
Speaker 1: Stand free from your ego, your mind will
Speaker 1: also be transcended, and then you get a
Speaker 1: glimpse of higher consciousness, will make
Speaker 1: that leap from relative to absolute
Speaker 1: perspectives.
Speaker 1: You start to see things differently.
Speaker 1: Reality will appear so differently.
Speaker 1: You get a glimpse of who you really are and
Speaker 1: who you can be.
Speaker 1: We all can be so much more than we think
Speaker 1: it's possible because we're always just
Speaker 1: thinking about this very rationally.
Speaker 1: We have to be unreasonable at a certain
Speaker 1: point.
Speaker 1: Life itself isn't very reasonable, is it so
Speaker 1: if we want to awaken in a way that's
Speaker 1: profound and outrageous, we have to also be
Speaker 1: unreasonable, take enormous risks and have
Speaker 1: unimaginable faith.